let's add some flare to your Rhythm
playing with five ways you can use the
pentatonic scale to create fills in
between your chords let's use a one two
progression in the key of G that's G
major going to a minor I'm focusing on
e-shaped chords that's rooted on string
six to allow you to freely move these
ideas to different keys different rout
notes it's important from the offset to
establish what I'm call the part
structure I.E how many beats you're
going to give the chord and how many
beats you give the filler across a four
beat measure we'll look to do two Beats
cord two beats
[Music]
fill number one pentatonic from the root
note this first idea is playing the
major pentatonic from the root on string
six with a hand in this bar cord shape
it sets you up perfectly for the 32
sliding major pentatonic scale this is
ideal for linking chord shapes
horizontally from The Roots you have
three notes on string six and two notes
on string five linking to the octave
root on string four finger one is on the
rout that's E3 then I go to E5 with
finger three then I slide into E7 with
finger three and I go A5 finger 1 A7
finger 3 and then D5 finger one this is
root 2 3 5 6 and back to the root we've
got six notes when including the octave
root to fit into two beats so we need to
use a 16th note figure the one I have
for you first of all is a three and a 4
e and three and a 4 e and
[Music]
moving back from the a minor to G we'll
do the opposite working down the scale
so we start on the root with finger
number one and then we go A7 A5 E7 E5
and then I like to slide down on finger
number one
[Music]
up down so I recommend you Loop these
ideas with the backing track or the
metronome at a Tempo that suits you idea
two Triad double stops now I'm
visualizing a Triad shape as I play this
pentatonic scale I'm coming off that
root note but within
it I see this this is a g Triad but G is
on string four we have the B which is
the third as the lowest note is b d and
g a g over b or
g/b but this I relate and you should to
back to this cuz it's one
of the four Triads of the E shape now
with a hand set up like this what I can
do is I can bar into the fifth fret and
I can hammer on first of all to that
third like that you can also do the same
move with the note on string five taking
two strings at a
[Music]
time so from the initial e shape I'm
seeing these two fingers I know I need
to put my index finger one there and
then the third finger grabs the note a
whole step above that finger just
jumping in to thank today's video
sponsor which is Me guitar blueprint is
my comprehensive guide teaching you
exactly how I visualize the fretboard
with the use of the cage system 39 per
string and interval shapes now with this
knowledge you will be able to hit the
good notes every time and take the
guesswork out of your soloing students
say it's like learning the source code
for the fretboard and they've been blown
away by the difference it's made in
their playing you can find out more with
the link down below or in the cards and
know this all the visualizations I am
teaching you today are covered in detail
in the course idea three is routing on
string number five getting even more
from this pentonic shape these exact
same Concepts will apply to the bar cord
shape rooted on string five when I call
the a shaped bar chord this being the C
as an example you see a
major C major in the a shape so so if
that's the bar chord then I
have the identical pensonic pattern
slide
[Music]
slide so everything you just leared from
the root note on string six is
immediately applicable to the root on
string
five if you're thinking of about a one
two in the key of C for example
then it all will work there as well idea
number four is a second octave slid now
that sliding pentatonic you've just been
playing on strings six and five can also
be played in a higher octave across
strings four and
[Music]
three
the starting point the visualization for
that is that octave
route on string four at the fifth fret
so it's D5 is the setup with finger one
and then it works in the same way once
again so root 2 3 so that's D5 D7 D9
then I have G7
G9 now where we might expect the root
note to be under finger number one in
fact it's on finger number two it's one
fret higher because the nature of
standard tuning the way the Guitar
Works as we move on to string two it's
one fret high if you know the octave
shapes that's the 42 octave three Frets
above so you make that
link with finger
two so those same fill ideas can then
apply into this second octave
[Music]
so it works in the exact same way
perhaps a little bit of a leap initially
for the eyes and visualizing the root
note up here but with a little practice
you'll see this comes very easily and
once again this pentatonic
pattern I think of being formed around
this right here now this is another G
over B it's another G Triad in a first
inversion but I think this is coming out
of the C shape okay that's a G chord in
the C shape under
[Music]
caged there it is so then those double
stop
ideas will also work in the same way the
only thing to look out for is that I'm
having to use two fingers to
grab the notes on string two and three
and then I'm hammering with finger
three there's a bar with finger one
across strings three and
[Music]
four and idea five is pentatonics in
position Around Bar chord shapes you can
always form a pentatonic scale around
this G chord in the E
shape the full to octave pattern looks
like
this
now you may see this as position one
major pentatonic or position two minor
pentatonic this numbering approach can
be a little confusing so I identify this
as the e-shape major pentatonic to be
relating it back to this bar chord so if
I play this I
know I've always got that pentatonic
under the hand using the second Octave
of this pentatonic scale starting from
string four you can use the same ideas
as the sliding pentatonic going up and
down the scale the double stop ideas are
also available but the guitar tuning
makes them a little trickier for the
fretting hand as you will see in just
one moment so going up the scale is not
too
demanding or descending same idea you'll
notice that there is a bit of a position
shift for finger
one I like to play it like
[Music]
this so finger one here is in the second
fret as come here it's in the third fret
and this is the issue with the double
stop ideas you got to just look out for
[Music]
that breaking that down on strings one
and two I've got these two notes right
here and I've got these two notes
available to me a whole Step
Above for some double stop Hammer on
ideas but as I move to Strings two and
three I need to use my second
finger and finger one
that's the back end of the
pentatonic and then I can use the third
finger again it's similar to what we saw
just before up here but you've got a
position
shift
here you didn't need to move the hand
but here you
do now for the a minor chord this is
probably the pentatonic box you have
already learned it's that position
one which is residing within that bar
chord shape I think of that as the I
call it the E minor pentatonic scale
because again it's working around an E
minor shape bar chord but with this
particular progression what you should
look out for is to we don't use the C
note there's a bit of a rub it doesn't
sound quite so nice if you try and put
that in for the fils in this progression
because we're in the key of G so it's
nice to stay with the G major pentatonic
so that would be the note of
B
[Music]
thank you for your time you practice
well and I'll see you in the next
lesson